yeah but how about this let's talk about
what's going on with the the lockdown
and I have this tweet from Brett
Weinstein so if those that aren't
familiar with Brett he is a professor in
exile evolutionary trade-offs telomeres
senescence and cancer the Dark Horse
podcast Brett is a smart fella and he
has this tweet it is insane that as the
evidence for vitamin D protective effect
mounts and though it appears the virus
is very rarely transmitted outdoors we
continue to instruct people to stay
indoors wear COV to is easily
transmitted and where they can't make
vitamin D and he's linking at this tweet
to Joe Rogan as vitamin D may reduce
susceptibility to kovat 19 associated
lung injury hold on do you think all
those people that were sun tanning their
bums are like yeah that's right we are
so we're so protected against CO vid
think about what this you know what I'm
talking about
I know unfortunately the bum tanning
yeah the bump Danny the people bump
tanning are thinking about anything
they're not thinking about this maybe
they don't read the article but maybe
they're like I'm just trying to get my
vitamin D in man but I think think about
what's going on right now if I'm having
fun today
think about what's going out the
lockdowns economic collapse you know
California's Los Angeles says we're
gonna send it for three months or until
we have a cure Korea's the Supreme Court
of Wisconsin struck down the extension
and almost immediately all the bars
popped open and they're flooded I'm sure
it will shoulder to shoulder party and
drink in like whoo freedom mm-hmm yeah
so one of the things that we've talked
about and a lot of the day we've seen
first of all the mortality rates a lot
lower than we thought
mm-hmm the infection rate is high
relative to other you know illnesses so
this is still dangerous and we got up
you got to pay attention focus on you
know be safe that's the easy way to put
it yeah we can't sustain this this
lockdown and even now like the Los
Angeles Times and other outlets are
pointing out the poor will suffer from
this yeah so finally they're getting on
board we're still seeing this weird
split where you know there's red states
and blue states but this is the crazy
thing the data has shown us that you're
more likely to get this if you're
indoors staying home yeah
it's 66 percent of people who have
contracted it during the lockdown were
staying at home yep
because going outside is good sunlight
is good and you're less likely to touch
the same things if you're out in the
open makes opposed to being in the house
so I'm getting all that vitamin D and
getting all that vitamin D so who is
gonna be most negatively impacted by
this older people older people yeah
city folk city folk who are in their
cubicle like box apartments with very
little sunlight
you know generating that vitamin D
deficiency because many of them are
probably eating trash they just order
right there they're not think like well
maybe that's not fair to say because I'm
sure they're eating similarly to pet no
no I wonder oh yeah I read an article
earlier about how basically the really
rich are can afford staying in and brra
with it and the really poor are staying
in so here's like the middle class are
going out and about but is that the
really rich include like how did they
break that down is it saying like my
income I I was gonna I was gonna bring
it up but it was really really long and
it was riddled with stories of stuff
that made no sense
yeah the article so I think it's that if
they did a general like income bracket
mmm-hmm
then New Yorkers have substantially
higher income okay oh they can't afford
many of them to stay inside and not have
vitamin D okay and then get sick resting
and you've got who's the audience's for
middle Americans go on the porch those
that's what those two doctors in
California we're talking about they're
basically saying if we stay inside we're
losing our natural immune system that we
build constantly like they were talking
about like the human body has viruses on
it all the time oh yeah non-stop always
we're always fighting off bacteria and
infections constantly so if we stay
inside and we don't get Sun then our
immune systems are just gonna go away so
the next time we go out we do actually
do get the kovat whatever you're gonna
get hit ten times as hard because you
have no immune system anymore I don't
know enough about how immune systems
work well that's what their whole video
is about they were talking about that
yes that's basically and then it got
taken down it's like mmm
and you kept getting taken down and I'm
pretty sure it's still being you know so
what they do to make the throw back
point forgive me if I'm gonna completely
you know not gonna complain about
BuzzFeed which is trying to get videos
banned now that I'm a fan of like you
know planned a McCartney these other
videos but we need to have a discussion
about whether or not we should or
shouldn't open now here's what gets
really really funny
I wonder if YouTube will ban us hmm
we're talking about how the lock I need
to be lifted here here what well Cassie
so they've gone after channels who have
been like you know the lockdown is BS
don't wear masks things like that yeah
but Wisconsin just ruled it
unconstitutional
hold on book who's sitting on that
really expensive oh is he
kitty brake troubles yeah what's new was
he sitting on a cat would do yep yeah
that was a very expensive well now we're
talking about cats don't even know we're
talking about I'm sorry I didn't want
anything to happen to that cuz we're
talking about a lotta really important
well I know yeah and vitamins are we
gonna get banned for talking yeah right
oh yeah sorry
what are we spending what am I supposed
a right now when Wisconsin says you
can't lock down Michigan says you have
to lock down yeah what is it yeah what
is it which is it is YouTube gonna ban
me which one do I get banned for now I
have no idea the World Health
Organization praised Sweden that didn't
lock down yeah but then the US was like
everybody got to lock down so I don't
know what I can or can't say I have no
and not all of the US some states were
like we're not looking down there fine
this is the funniest thing like going on
when it comes to the election do do
people like do these these anti-trump
people think that the Americans will
blame Donald Trump for their governor
locking their state down do you think
the dem states are just trying to like
hold it off as long as possible so maybe
they can just win something people are
that stupid
something Trump said maybe honestly I
think so what did Trump said yes so
Trump said he thinks that they are
trying to keep it the economy shut down
until the election and I was like holy
cow
can that be right and then the more I
thought about it the more I was like
maybe the economy was doing really
really well that's what I was a little
that's just blue states that are already
gonna give their electoral votes that
will trump anyway
so you know there's a CNN poll showing
that Trump is up in all the battleground
states yeah Trump's got a secret voter
base so I don't know if that makes sense
because the democratic states that are
enforcing these lockdowns are sabotaging
themselves like it's we were talking
about this before it's true about
emotion versus logical politicking you
know where if like you had an apartment
and there was one guy who was constantly
knocking here a bunch of roommates and
he was like everybody's got to pitch in
their fair share to clean up everyone
would groan and the one guy would be
like if you make me in charge the house
everybody gets pizza they'd be like yeah
a pizza and then the house falls apart
because it's easy and not you know yeah
they vote for the easy thing to do
mm-hmm well now you've got a bunch of
people that clearly want to go to the
bars like Wisconsin everybody flooded
the bars they didn't care I wouldn't do
that I wouldn't hear it I wouldn't but
hey man people want to bars are too
expensive I like drinking out but people
restaurants and stuff and barbershops
like people were like I don't care I'm
growing up yeah it's true these people
are not happy with their their
democratic governors man you think about
what happened this pandemic and I'll
tell you what I wouldn't be surprised if
like conservatives greatly outnumber
democrats when it's all over everyone
buying guns you know figuring out what's
like the laws are like another you see
that viral video where the gun shop
owner was complaining about first-time
gun buyers know was a he was like i
swear these first-time gun buyers you
come into my store you can't get the
weapon no you can't pay me more to get
it faster
you got background checks you got
waiting periods how about the next time
someone tries to take your stuff away
you vote against it yeah you got really
angry good for him because in LA good
yeah man in LA these people are showing
up like oh no the world isn't you know
we're an emergency I better get a weapon
and it's like where were you when
everyone was saying like now you're
coming in and shocked yeah at these are
the laws you vote for you I can't get a
gun now yeah because you voted to make
it hard to get a gun that call it's you
voted for these people you know yeah I
mean speaking of that though apparently
there was a an amendment to I think it
was the the Patriot Act that would have
taken away the ability of the government
to spy on browsing history okay and it
was it was relatively bipartisan but it
was mostly Democrats who were voting to
amend it to her
this power and it was mostly Republicans
who voted against it huh
it failed by one vote so the government
retains the power to warrantless lis get
your browser history it's ridiculous up
yeah this was a problem I have when
people are alike go to vote through the
Republicans I'm like why so they can
empower the federal government's FISA
search powers they just did somewhat
extended FISA powers and it was I can
8080 to 16 vote like all these like
bipartisan support for him you know what
man the Democrats want to come out and
complain Donald Trump is a fascist we
must stop him but let's vote to give him
more executive power
that's why it's all fake it's all fake
man yep they all want the power right
they're like they're like well when I'm
in office I definitely want to be able
to warrant lease you know spy on
American citizen so okay I got a vote
for now but anyway back to the lockdown
yeah I think these Democratic governors
are like they're they're ending they're
like they're destroying their careers it
feels like it yeah who's gonna want to
vote for him especially Whitmer it's
like what are you doing Ritchie is queen
Karen she really is check this out this
is crazy this is crazy this so people
are getting really mad about this I
guess of course they are supervisor Jim
Desmond publishes video messages calling
for immediate reopening of San Diego
County businesses apparently he said
something like rise up and people like I
don't that's a real quote other people
were sharing you didn't see that was
listening to it yeah I didn't listen to
the full thing it's comments long and
well maybe maybe he did maybe he didn't
let's just find out no he said rise to
the challenge he didn't say rise up okay
okay so people were being hyperbolic but
he basically points out he makes some
really really great points um without
going in everything here's the guy who's
smart go to the small mom-and-pop shops
that are having their businesses
destroyed yeah
and I'll tell you what they're gonna
tell you why is it that I sell clothing
but Walmart gets to keep say open
selling clothing and I can't you know
why are the big-box stores and the
corporation's being benefited from this
lockdown why am I being held back yeah
and these and and these Democratic
governors who are like and the media
they're rooting for the billionaires
while pretending like they're not I
don't get it I don't know man
I think there's just there's no there's
no principle behind what there's
it's just I'm angry yep
I'll tell you what though I'm looking
forward to go to the movies I can't I'm
gonna go bowling bowling I brought I
brought my bowling ball across the
country to bowl again I even have my
bowling shoes that's right they still
fit me from when I was 11
what yeah bowling yeah I got I got
bowling shoes at 11 yeah but you know
what when I was younger I always I would
always say I was size 12 my feet are
size 12 but it's too big and then my
bowling shoes they were I got him a
little smaller cuz I was not a size 12
and my shoes are always way too big for
me I wonder how many people did I wonder
how many people actually want to go out
though you know I bet a lot of people
would you go bowling right now
definitely if I could yeah yeah for sure
that's what bowling alleys right there
well I'm saying like
jam-packed tons of people all braden and
sweaty and touching everything movies
yes person behind you coughs not
necessarily sneezes two rows back
sneezes boom all over the corners I've
got my own bowling ball to you do I want
to put my whole my hands in other
people's holes that's right I said that
phrasing yeah oh it's a good time today
oh man it's kinda it's kind of a weird
it's been a weird experience man yeah
it's been weird I'm not ready for it to
be over once my life I hope ready like I
wasn't I wasn't that impacted by it we
work for we work from young studio so I
wasn't that impacted by I'm a gamer when
they locked his name yeah video games
and we got a skate park podcast yeah we
got some crazy yeah we just been skating
the ramp I'm like it kind of I like I
like going out and having like you know
pow wows at restaurants like sitting
down talking about stuff it's true and I
do miss thought too
and what'd I miss - is non political
conversations yeah because you know
there s that's all it is now it is
because Gove it in politics because when
you can't leave nothing happens right
and so it's just like I don't know the
one thing that has to have the people
who are still getting paid still working
or doing stuff that's what's crazy about
all
this the journalists are still getting
paid the politicians are still getting
paid and they're the ones mostly being
like I got running down it's like yeah
okay how about we stop paying you and
then we can you know then we can have
that conversation about who you know
what we should or shouldn't you don't
seem very essential nah I don't know man
what are you looking forward to the most
when you get your freedom back outside
of bowling now you mention bowling I
yeah well we'll see yeah I don't know
probably going and checking out
Philadelphia I went to I went to high
school here yeah going he's funny like
right when you got here they yeah I got
here I'm like man I haven't been here as
an adult I get to like really experience
this place that I loved as a kid I have
a lot of I had a lot of really good
friends you know in this area I would
like to read you know meet them all and
as adults we can like go out yeah it's
cool I I really remember Philadelphia
being an awesome city and I was able to
go like twice since I got here and that
sucks like I really want to go explore
maybe it's time to move to Texas man
leave Philadelphia but I want to
experience for though I'm saying because
you know Philadelphia PA I think
extended the lockdown I know yeah that's
what this yeah so even if first of all
New Jersey's not going to extend because
North Jersey is basically New York Metro
right Pennsylvania's so where were were
in the thick of it man I know Joe Rogan
mentioned in passing you know he might
want over to Texas I say that mentioning
in passing because the media loves to
like latch on anything he says yeah and
then light it on fire he's like I might
vote for Bernie and then they're like
Joe Biden our Joe Rogan endorses Bernie
Sanders Bernie ran as an a dirty move
man did you imagine like one day it's
like as an ad with you being like the
guy inside of context and like yeah but
he said he might move to Texas and so
I'm thinking he's got a point man I
don't know about Texas though they have
miniature cows there Tim they have
miniature cows in Texas okay done yeah
decision is made hold it there you know
we were like cows we're lost the country
it was amazing what do you mean it'll
cows yes run around like up to your hip
there you making a little milk you know
I'm good and then you got little cows
man they're so cute and they could
rescue cows eat grass oh yeah they do
I'm not going to eat the cows well good
no yeah the cows you hang out with them
man they're your friends like I guess I
hear cows like music they do yeah they
do they're like jamming yeah you go play
music in the field should like make like
a drum pad system so they can walk and
hit drums and they'd be like Oh what was
that there was a right at viral a reddit
post of the day about something called
like the the coaling or something the
what the coning or whole name it's a
Swedish song they sing the cows okay and
all the cows come running over to this
woman who's singing they all like stand
and watch I've seen videos of people
doing like trumpet playing trumpet and
the cows are like they all come to watch
and they're like oh that is a great
sound yeah man cows are cool maybe
because we artificially selected them
there there are cool animals I hung out
with cows before that doesn't mean yeah
yeah my uncle has a farm he's got some
cows maybe maybe you know back in the
day when we were breeding cows the
people who were Brayden um would likely
be jamming out in their loot or whatever
yeah Cowboys used to play yeah yeah then
the house would come on by me back I
like this one let's make more of them
yeah we could have we could have
chickens somebody what was that funny
super chair guy the other day they were
like Americans harp on about their
freedom but you can't even own chickens
[Laughter]
it's honestly it's the closer you are to
a big city the less yeah you can be
rural unless you can do anything
basically is so annoying
yeah because everyone's crammed together
yeah and it's like crazy they say you
know your rights and where my rights
beginner or whatever like the general
idea is because everybody is different
in what they're willing to accept okay
they make like there's a lowest common
denominator to rise legal okay yeah if
you're in the middle of nowhere who's
gonna complain like you could light a
flaming arrow and fire it straight up
and then run okay fun sound smart no
bright means like a very stupid thing to
do but you got no neighbors as long as
you don't like burn a forest down or
something nobody's gonna care okay you
do that in a city and you're gonna be
arrested in charge
or something crazy let's probably you're
gonna come free in there to be like are
you nuts
like you can you can love it like I I
know some people who live in the middle
of nowhere they got a bunch of guns and
they go in the back and they have like a
shooting area set up and like they have
a range and everything yeah but my buddy
in Texas there's a funny viral meme
where it's like something is that
there's a target on a fence in a
suburban area so there's neighbors right
next door and it shows like it's like a
woman with like a rifle and she's
pointing at the fence yeah if I'm at the
target and it's like it's clearly not
real right the joke is like firing into
the neighbor's yard whatever and then a
bunch of you know like lefty people are
getting triggered by it like what are
these people are not and it's like it's
not real that's the joke
yeah you're falling for the rights means
again yo cuz weed meme this lockdown
stuff has really made me want to
accelerate not necessarily buggin out
which is getting more space to do more
stuff like now you know so so we and I
had this five acre Miami place yeah and
we had a 22 pellet gun and a bunch of
co2 cartridges and we would just like
ice you know I sure have that gun
oh you do I do it's an Arizona yeah it's
not bad it was like a Remington or
something it's it's pretty good it's
pretty good yeah I mean you probably
killed somebody with that yeah totally
took him in the absolutely soft spot I
mean if you're close enough it'll go
right through their head probably it was
brutal is it 22 yeah that's crazy
but it was it was air so I think it was
like 17 fit with a feet per second it
was it was no idea no idea but we would
we would put little co2 cans and then
you know put it down and we'd like and
then it'll go you know we'd also blow up
lithium batteries yeah we had a lot of
fun in Miami yeah but that's when you
have space you could do whatever you
want true that's true
so no one cared I couldn't imagine being
one of these city fault you know trapped
in New York City mm-hmm these it's it's
like people gonna turn into the Joker
man probably they're like I've seen some
weird videos like people are doing the
one one someone had like a studio
apartment and they made a stop-motion on
their floor you can like mounted the
camera and then because like what else
you gonna do you're basically in prison
you know what I think that's why that's
why in New York they've all been going
out disregarding all the the orders
yeah and so then who really it's
impacted by it for
people I guess not the rich New Yorkers
he can afford to deal with it nobody'll
mess then they pay you know that said
that that that tends to be how it goes
but I mean for us here I didn't really
notice anything I've gone out there's
been no issues I mean there's some masks
everywhere are they yeah it's all it's a
law I guess in Jersey that you have to
wear a mask
period if you if you go out you have to
be wearing a mask well I mean it's not
that hard to wear a mask that bad what
if this is like you should just open it
up and everywhere masks
wash your hands keep it clean how many
how many people do you think or I don't
know to ask this question but I imagine
there's a lot of people who are gonna
get really ripped a lot of people are
gonna get really out of shape okay
padding I'm like the sport you do that's
sure like if I was if I was in New York
like we wouldn't be skateboarding so we
wouldn't be doing any exercise but we're
out here we got a backyard we got a mini
ramp and a flat so we're skating all the
time yeah that's true sighs mm-hmm
there's probably a lot of people that
are probably losing it because they
can't play a basketball and they can't
play football and they're trapped in a
cubicle yeah man and there's time for
those people but I imagine a lot of them
are probably doing exercises and stuff
inside yeah just doing whatever there
was a funny video where it's like a
bunch of people were protesting for
having you know to get gyms to reopen
yeah so they started doing push-ups and
squats on the ground perfect and then
everybody was like wait what why don't
you why don't you just do that yeah
you're literally working out yeah thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you